madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
l'actualité décidément n'est qu'une
succession de surprises d'événements
parfois de choc
ainsi ce soir ce journal de 20h aurait
dû commencer par ce grand problème qui
enfièvre la france depuis six mois je
parlais des élections législatives qui
ont lieu demain et dont le président de
la république vient d'évoquer l'enjeu
d'après ce que nous savons le président
de la république monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing n'interviendra d'ailleurs plus
avant le second met à 16h17 après-midi
un premier télégramme nous est parvenu 4
mots sur une dépêche pour y apprendre
que claude françois et est mort et puis
à 18h13 un autre télégramme en
provenance celui-là de tel-aviv
un groupe de fedayins s'est emparé d'un
autobus cet après midi non loin de la
capitale israélienne cet autobus a été
encerclé par les forces de l'ordre de
furieux combats se déroule pour
l'instant sur ce qui se passe en israël
c'est semble-t-il la confusion la plus
totale nous n'en savons rien sinon une
trentaine d'enfants seraient
actuellement à bord de ces autobus andré
ses mains nous appelle de jérusalem
vous l'avez compris il y a des victimes
donc en israël et parmi ces victimes
probablement des enfants nous aurons
peut-être une nouvelle communication
téléphonique avec andré ses mains avant
la fin de ce journal
nous attendons aussi des images par
satellite d'israël à 16h10 je vous le
disais donc nous apprenions la mort de
claude françois un décès qui d'ores et
déjà secoué toute une partie de la
france
tous ceux qui parce qu'ils étaient parce
qu'il était de leur temps de leur époque
on fait de claude françois leur idole
comme les générations qui les ont
précédés ont eu comme idole edith piaf
damian tino rossi mistinguett ou bien
maurice chevelle claude françois c'était
je vous disais donc l'idole d'une partie
de la jeunesse tout ce qui cet après
midi depuis 16h10 se sont amassés devant
son domicile boulevard exelmans en 16e
le comprenez bien ainsi et ils étaient
nombreux très nombreux
je vous propose de retrouver sur place
notre reporter jean jacques dufour
le chanteur qui allait avoir 40 ans et
mort de l'accident le plus stupide qui
soit il est mort électrocuté au 8e étage
dans son appartement
les quelques proches présents sont
consternés il attendait le chanteur sur
un plateau de télévision
quand ils ont appris ce soir claude
françois avait organisé un dîner
ici au 46 boulevard exelmans cette mort
a surpris tout le monde
il est 15 heures claude françois quitte
sa terrasse où il profite des premiers
rayons de soleil de l'année il à chaud
il se rend dans la salle de bain la une
ampoule marche mal
claude françois essayer de la changer et
il s'écroule
la jeune femme avec qui il vit appelle
immédiatement les pompiers ceux-ci font
un massage cardiaque le coeur repart
malheureusement il s'arrêtera à nouveau
et définitivement
il est environ 15h
lucien salle son nouvel agent me disais
tout à l'heure
sa manie du perfectionnisme toujours
vouloir que tout marche parfaitement
bien depuis que la nouvelle est
officielle
des barrières ont été installées autour
du domicile quelques admiratrices en
pleurs et des badauds 200 peut-être sont
groupés derrière sur un banc en face de
l'immeuble des inscriptions un peu
désuète comme à toi claude pour la vie
la mère du chanteur viendra tout à
l'heure elle n'était pas à paris cet
après midi claude françois avait deux
enfants
pour reparler de lefrançois dans
quelques minutes nous avons invité rico
macias qui est avec nous ce soir nous
allons retrouver dans une minute claude
françois avec 39 ans en 1962 son nom
était à paris au pit parade de la
chanson française
sa carrière vous avez pu le constater
n'avait pas connu des clipse depuis
les coupes ou ses costumes pastel les
roses de l'amour au coin des lèvres ne
sera jamais bien je vais traîner sept
ans se tend et des poussières dans les
orchestres on en est dans des petites
boîtes la spring is dans n'importe quoi
pourvu comme de les venger enfin ou
presque ou pas assez selon les cas c'est
tout ça fait 15 ans je suis arrivé de
l'egypte quand on a été renfloué et
c'est le cas de le dire pour le canal de
suez 1 156 je me suis retrouvé donc
j'avais 14 1/2 15 ans sur la côte d'azur
et du travail et j'ai traîné de boîte en
boîte et de fil en aiguille j'ai ça
c'est une naturellement vous était
toujours blond toujours qu'alain lui qui
lançait sans craintes un chemise de
certains outils grèce amoureuse de son
fan club pour qu'elle en déchire les
lambeaux il gardera pour toutes les
petites filles qui révèle lui l'image de
l'éternelle jeune homme du prince
charmant de discothèques qu'il avait
imposée avec un incroyable succès imposé
non sans travail car pour passer en 20
ans des petites boîtes de saint tropez
de monte carlo ou plus grands music hall
et devenir un pdg de poids il faut être
la dynamo son moindre raté qu'était
claude françois
j'ai bel avenir dans un métier où les
vedettes se fabrique des articles de
cotillons se lance comme des flèches en
papier pour retomber six mois après
claude françois sous son apparence
d'adolescentes prolonger cash à une
volonté de métal un esprit d'entreprise
de vieux renard une vigilance une ardeur
une ambition de débutants ils n'auraient
pu se contenter de chanter des tubes
au contraire il avait créé un journal
podium où il avait l'élégance de ne pas
se tailler la part du lion et de
partager les couvertures avec d'autres
petits roi soleil il éditait ses disques
avait une agence de mannequins et
produisent m lui-même ses spectacles il
rebondissait dans la vie comme sur la
scène petite balle pleine de vitalité de
désir d'aller plus loin d'être toujours
le premier d'avoir plus de courriers
d'admiratrices il faut l'avoir vu avant
un gala fébrile veillant à tout pour une
idole chaque représentation est là ça
m'est jamais venu à lever parce qu'ils
savent encore hier il veut toujours plus
il avait même lancé son parfum ou noir
étonnant étonnamment nommé si on ne sait
pas que les vies de velours rose ont
toujours une doublure sombre on peut
sourire dans les photos entouré d'une
épouse éphémère d'enfants jeu long mais
toutes lumières éteintes on mène une vie
de combat où l'amour est balancé par la
haine des voyous tirs sur votre voiture
on se retrouve une nuit après un gala le
visage en sang dans un procès plus forcé
au repos pour épuisement nerveux après
une tournée trop longue
d'abord je
j'arrive sur une scène je chante je
danse pendant une heure si les gens sont
contents je progresse et deux heures
s'ils le veulent je m'amuse j'aime ça et
je fais ça parce que j'adore s'appuie
sur mon avis ça ils valent plus rien bon
je veux ça parce que je ne veux que ça
je suis à l'extrémisme une grande
qualité était peut-être son dynamisme et
sa santé c'est ce qu'on mettra le plus à
son cours ses admiratrices toute son
influence n'avait pas du début drogue
d'appétit de cafard de cruauté ou de
mort claude françois chante l amour
tendre les fleurs des soirs d'été et les
chagrins d'amour qui se console mais ce
soir les petites filles sont
inconsolables haricots macias vous avez
accepté de nous rejoindre ce soir dans
ce studio d'antenne 2 pour évoquer la
mémoire de claude françois
vous l'avez rencontrée je crois pour la
première fois en 1962 vous débarquez
d'algérie jimmy devallet dès le premier
contact avec lui mais il faisait un
spectacle avec sylvie vartan et les
beatles à l'olympia et c'était déjà un
débutant très célèbre juge avait été le
voir il m'avait très bien reçus il
m'avait dit qu'il venait d'égypte et
comme je lui ai dit que je venais de
constantine cdd des liens se sont tout
de suite formé entre nous et pas besoin
de vous origines respectives
pourquoi voulons vraiment mais je crois
que c'est surtout ses 7,7 amour qu'on a
notre métier qui fait que nous sommes
une véritable famille du show business
quoi qu'on en dise on est vraiment très
liées très solidaire et je ne suis pas
le seul à être bouleversée par la mort
de claude françois qui pour moi est
quelque chose encore de j'arrive pas
encore à réaliser parce que c'est
tellement subi bon on obligé de dire des
banalités mais ce genre de banalités
sons deviennent très importante parce
que c'est c'est quand même quelqu'un de
notre famille qui s'en va est un grand
chanteur populaire puis je dois ajouter
en plus que quand on est aimé par les
enfants c'est qu'on n'a jamais triché et
que le françois et c'est un très grand
champion
en plus d'un grand ami oui françois je
le disais beaucoup d'enfants ont dû
pleurer ce soir en attendant et en
apprenant la nouvelle de la mort de
claude françois les enfants finalement
c'était son public et je crois qu'ils en
tiraient tout de même une certaine
fierté quand même oui parce qu'on peut
pas tricher avec les enfants et françois
était loin de tricher puisque c'était un
perfectionniste
moi je les ai vus travailler travailler
très très bien c'est un vrai
professionnel
en plus il avait une volonté hors du
commun hors du commun on vous a vu dans
beaucoup d'émissions ensemble
la manche albert raisner à l'époque de a
été notre notre première émission parce
que c'était la première fois qu'on nous
qu'on sortait des sentiers battus mais
j'avais on avait fait des choses sont en
dehors de la chanson je l'avais un peu
limité il m'avait chambre et il m'avait
imiter lui-même alors qu'on n'est pas du
tout des imitateurs
on s'était amusé comme de vrais
camarades quand je pense à en mai sans
qu'on est dans une classe d'école et
qu'on perd un ami un camarade qui est
tout près de soi pendant des années des
années on a l'impression que de même on
disait que claude françois et est devenu
un business man et qu'il était même
disons très dur en affaires il était
quand même respectueux des amitiés qu'il
avait avec oui ceux qui avaient connu
plutôt savez moi je ne connaissais pas
très bien ses activités commerciales et
tout ça mais pour moi il a toujours
essayé toujours espérer artistes et les
rapports qu'il avait avec n'est pas
seulement moi avec michel sardou johnny
hallyday ou les autres cantons on se
voyait dans les émissions faisait pas du
tout lé aucune allusion ses affaires
commerciales et ou bien sûr c'était un
business man dont j'ai appris comme vous
tous mais par pudeur on ne parlait pas
de ça entre nous on était vrai des vrais
comment la durée du je m'excuse de
répéter ce mot là mais c'est vrai depuis
cet après midi il ya des centaines
peut-être des milliers de personnes qui
essaient de se frayer un chemin vers le
boulevard exelmans a été barrée je dois
dire par la police pour éviter justement
que trop de personnes puissent entrer
dans le domicile de françois
vous comprenez ce phénomène du fan ce
phénomène de la grande foule
tout ce que je sais c'est que claude
françois accompagné la vie de milliers
de gens de millions de gens tous les
jours quand on écoute ses disques à la
radio ou comble quand on le voyait à la
télévision est rentré dans la famille
des gens il rentrait dans le coeur des
gens et il n'y a pas mieux que les
enfants et la jeunesse pour être vite
réceptif ce genre de choses je comprends
très bien ce phénomène parce que tout
simplement que le françois et est un
chanteur populaire
merci beaucoup et rico avec le françois
la france a en effet fait connaissance
d'un phénomène celui des fanatiques ce
qu on raccourcit on appelle les fans
s'ils étaient présents un peu partout
des claude françois arrivé il était là
dans les studios de télévision dans les
salles de spectacle il était là tout le
temps de jour comme de nuit devant le
domicile aussi du chanteur les fans ce
n'est pas un phénomène nouveau vous le
savez rudolf valentino avait les siens
mézil
cela était d'un style peut-être tout
neuf
de l'adoration muette on était passé en
effet l'exhibitionniste et peut être
parfois à l'excès
75 millions de disques vendus en 15 ans
1500 cas là à travers la france un
physique de petit train un pays
prématurément et un dynamisme débutante
à son premier bal
voici claude françois cloclo l'idole des
petites françaises
et
une nuée de fissures chaque déplacement
de claude françois
certaines passent des jours entiers à
l'attendre et nuit à dormir sur son
palier qui sont elles des folles d
hystérique
une d'entre elles myriam s'explique dans
un livre tout ce qui vient de lui et
merveilleux puisque automatiquement si
j'aime tout ce qui vient de lui et
merveilleux rien il y en a jamais assez
chaque jour c'est un jour nouveau c'est
pas la même chose pourtant c'est
toujours le même ici chaque faute chose
on met pourtant il donne très peu
bah oui je ne demande pas beaucoup peu
qu'ils me donnent c'est déjà bien
c'est à dire depuis combien de temps
ouais j'ai vu en 11 ans quand j'ai
commencé à le découvrir
et puis j'en ai 20 l'horreur ça fait
neuf ans et 7 pourrait durer durer
encore combien est avant tout la vie
parce que maintenant je sais que ya que
lui qui compte on se raccroche à
n'importe quelle forme d'idéal les uns
jardine les autres jouent aux cartes les
troisièmes poursuivre ma les autres
peines y est c'est fait défis qui se
raccroche à un symbole quelconque un
artiste du tout quelque chose qui brille
ou quelque chose qui a l'air de toujours
heureux d'être toujours en forme et des
et de refléter si vous préférez une
forme de bonheur dans la société
avec beaucoup de français ce soir nous
lisons adieu à claude françois
mais revenons donc à ce qui aurait dû
être l'événement de cette journée je
veux parler de la politique française
c'est des élections législatives qui
auront lieu demain je crois que vous
savez bon je prends à peu près tout sur
ces élections sur le plan politique il
nous reste que même à fixer un peu le
car jean-marie cotteret vous êtes avec
nous ce soir
alors il ya à peu près 35 millions 35
millions cinq cent mille électeurs qui
sont ils ces électeurs français qui vont
demain déposé un bulletin dans l'urne
alors d'abord il faut rappeler
qu'effectivement il a 34 millions six
cent mille électeurs pour la métropole
et sur ses 34 millions 600 mille il y à
un million huit cent mille jeunes c'est
un phénomène nouveau
selon les statistiques de l'institut
national d'études démographiques et du
ministère de l'intérieur du john ce sont
le 18 21 ans qui ont le droit de voter
pour la première fois pour donner juste
exactement et il ya eu évidemment des
répercussions sur la composition du
corps électoral pour la première fois le
corps électoral est le plus jeune depuis
1936 la moyenne d'âge est d'environ 44
ans un petit peu plus de 44 ans feront
remonter avant la guerre 1914 pour
trouver un électorat encore plus jeunes
l'album également fait des recherches
sur les catégories professionnelles car
il ya eu beaucoup de glissements depuis
20 ans oui ce sont essentiellement les
travaux de l'institut national d'études
démographiques
il ya évidemment des changements assez
profonds en 1978 on a constaté d'abord
qu'il y à 43% des électeurs qui sont
économiquement inactif
c'est à dire les femmes les retraités
les jeunes et les chômeurs
il reste évidemment c'est la population
active alors parmi cette population
active
les changements sont intervenus le
premier changement c'est la diminution
de la population agricole
en effet en 1954 il y avait cent
cinquante-cinq électeurs sur 1000 qui
vivaient de l'agriculture il n'y en a
plus aujourd'hui que 55 le tiers le
tiers ce qui évidemment une diminution
considérable diminution également pour
les commerçants qui de 78 sur 1000 en
1954 ne sont plus que 47 la population
ouvrière est à peu près stationnaire une
légère augmentation et enfin un
phénomène tout à fait nouveau la grosse
augmentation des professions libérales
des cadres supérieurs et moyens cols
blancs et cols blancs et même un peu
plus qui en 1954 étaient 123 et qui sont
actuellement 220 qu'est ce que léo est
la proportion la plus importante du
corps électoral est toujours des
électeurs on n'arrive pas à classer les
gens dansent dans les fiches il ya les
électeurs flottants est ce qu'ils
représentent une part importante de
l'électorat français
oui les électeurs flottants constituait
probablement l'élément le plus
intéressant du corps électoral
malheureusement c'est aussi l'électorat
le plus mal connus on peut considérer je
crois qu'en gros il y a trois millions à
4 millions d'électeurs qui sont
politiquement indéterminée ce sens que
les spécialistes de la communication
appelle l'électorat critique et qui au
gré des événements vont tantôt à gauche
tantôt à droite mais ce sont eux qui en
définitive détiennent la décision finale
surtout quand une élection se joue à
deux ou trois points et là nous restons
sa part deux derniers albums nous
verrons donc ça demain jean-marie
cotteret nous vous retrouverons
d'ailleurs je crois de m'asseoir dans
notre corps est spécial élections nous
aurons tout le temps je crois d'évoquer
tous ces problèmes et de faire à ce
moment-là les classifications
ce cieux sociologique et politique de
l'électorat français car il nous reste
encore un dernier problème a évoqué qui
vote nous venons de le voir mais surtout
comment peut-on vote et philippe
harrouard s'est penché sur le code
électoral ces derniers jours alors je
vous propose en sa compagnie de faire un
rapide rapide pardon tour d'horizon de
cette question comment voter pour voter
une seule obligation être inscrit sur
une liste électorale
votre bureau de vote est indiqué sur
votre carte d'électeur qui est la même
que la dernière fois
couleur bleu permet cette carte
d'électeur vous devez la présenter au
moment de voter ainsi qu'une pièce
d'identité obligatoire dans les communes
de plus de 5000 habitants
si vous avez des gares et votre carte
d'électeur ou si vous n'avez pas encore
reçu
vous pouvez quand même voter en vous
rendant dans le même lieu que la
dernière fois
il vous suffit de justifier de votre
identité en présentant votre carte
nationale ou le livret de famille ou le
dernier conduire ou un passeport ou
votre carte de sécurité sociale etc
avant de voter vous passer dans
l'isoloir afin de placer votre bulletin
dans une ambre attention l'enveloppent
comme le bulletin ne doivent porter
aucune trace d'inscription et ne doivent
pas être froissés sous peine d'être
déclarées nulles au moment du
dépouillement
la plupart des bureaux de vote sont
ouverts de 8 heures à 18 heures dans les
grandes villes le scrutin est prolongée
jusqu'à 19 ou 20 heures dans quelques
endroits il peut débuter dès 7 heures du
matin demain il y aura donc les
élections et cela c'est votre problème
mais il y aura aussi les résultats de
ces élections et cela c'est notre
problème antenne 2 associés à nos
confrères d'europe numéro un et du point
se propose de vous faire vivre en direct
et toute la soirée bien sûr jusqu'à une
heure avancée de la nuit même le
dépouillement de ce vote nous vous
proposerons aussi les premiers
commentaires des hommes politiques dès
20h30 et les analyses politiques de
votre vote
dernière répétition de cette soirée
exceptionnelle que vous vivrez en direct
de l'hôtel de lassay pour les résultats
des élections législatives
premier rendez vous 18h55
puis dès 20h nous vous donnerons
l'estimation honeywell bull c2i et
pourcentages sont tenus par la majorité
et par l'opposition
les résultats de chaque circonscription
vous seront donnés dès l'instant où il
nous parviendrons toutes les demi-heures
une synthèse
tous les résultats seront visualisées
par des cas et des tableaux ainsi que
des photos minute par minute
on pourrait suivre l'évolution du
scrutin avec la carte publiée par le
point
enfin au cours de la soirée deux grands
débats en direct
mettant aux prises les grands leaders
des formations politiques auront lieu
est régulièrement les réactions des
grandes villes de province 80
journalistes d'europe 1 et d'antenne 2
seront mobilisés à paris et en province
pour vous permettre de suivre cette
soirée exceptionnelle animée par etienne
mougeotte et jean pierre elkabbach bien
et nous essaierons de tenir jusqu'à 2
heures du matin ou trois heures s'il le
faut et puis en marge de ces élections
législatives vous le savez il y a les
quelques controverses qui ont été qui
ont émaillé les derniers jours de la
campagne qui ont été portées depuis
devant les tribunaux c'est ainsi que
monsieur gilbert gantier qui est
candidat dans le 16e arrondissement a
été condamné aujourd'hui pour
diffamation envers monsieur gris attrait
monsieur gonthier se présente comme
candidat de la majorité
monsieur grille autres et a obtenu le
soutien de l'udf et aussi du rpr autre
procès celui qui opposait monsieur
chinois monsieur estier tous deux
candidates dans le xviiie arrondissement
monsieur gino poursuivait en diffamation
taux d astier il a été débouté
voilà donc pour la politique la campagne
électorale est maintenant terminée c'est
à vous c'est à nous aussi électeurs et
électrices de nous prononcer
les gangsters qui se sont attaqués à la
succursale du crédit lyonnais et de
vence dans les alpes-maritimes n'ont pas
perdu leur temps cette nuit cette
succursale avait 300 coffre 118 ont été
ouverts ont été couverts pardon en une
nuit et bien sûr vidés de leur contenu
les gangsters aurait ainsi emmené pour
10 millions de francs de butin
les angleterre les enquêteurs pardon
reste perplexe il semble qu'à ou deux
des malfaiteurs
après avoir loué un coffre il ya quelque
temps se soit laissée enfermer dans la
salle
et cette nuit il est réussi à introduire
un complice dans les lieux les trois
hommes ont pensé
ouvert les cov et ils sont ressortis par
la porte principale de la banque
l'enquète a commencé pour l'instant nous
ne connaissons pas encore les premiers
résultats en sport deux sujets d'intérêt
aujourd'hui paris-nice et les
championnats du monde de patinage vous
propose de commencer par le cyclisme la
première grande course à étapes de la
saison se terminait aujourd'hui et dans
le contre-la-montre le leader du
classement général
cleitman l'a emporté devant bernard
hinault le hollandais étaient donc
visiblement le plus fort n'est demain à
gagner mais l'un de ses adversaires
bernard hinault a bien failli renverser
la situation en sa faveur
il a dû concéder néanmoins 10 secondes
hollandais dans les 11 kilomètres de la
montée du col d'eze
cela lui a tout de même permis de
prendre la deuxième place au classement
final
mais ce n'est pas la peur du gendarme
qui a fait perdre à zoetemelk cette
course au soleil
carpe le hollandais de france a été
battue par un très grand nettement
c'était l'un des favories hotmail qui a
déjà trois fois vainqueur dans ce tome z
il a perdu 26 secondes dans l'ascension
est aussi la deuxième place au
classement final
ça promet
et si le bourguignon michel laurent a
causé la plus grande déception se
classant seulement cinquième c'est bien
le plus fort qui l'a emporté guerric
détails l'hollandais à lunettes âgé de
27 ans originaire d'amsterdam il aura
porté le maillot blanc de leader de bout
tombe
vainqueur du prologue et de la 1re étape
à auxerre il a su tout au long de
l'épreuve contrôler la situation
avec l'aide d'une équipe efficace et ici
sur les pentes du col d'eze seul avec
lui même il est resté vraiment le plus
fort c'est l'homme en forme des débuts
de seize premiers batman 2e i know à 19
secondes troisième hotmail qu'à trente
et une secondes
autre centre d'intérêt pour les sportifs
donc les championnats du monde de
patinage artistique qui se déroule au
canada à ottawa très exactement
hier c'est un américain charles tickner
qui l'a emporté devant un allemand de
l'est aujourd'hui
chez les dames c'est une allemande de
l'est qui est monté sur la plus haute
marche du podium
and push à 18 ans elle a réussi à
préserver un avantage acquis deux jours
auparavant dans les figures imposées
devant l'américaine linda fratianni sa
plus dangereuse rivale et l'italienne
soussane adria
à l'époque j'avais laissé échapper le
titre l'an dernier à tokyo à cause d'une
mauvaise réception après un triple salto
pour sceller cette victoire aujourd'hui
anne peuple n'a raté aucun son aucune
fille
and push 18 ans de la république
démocratique allemande
avant de clore ce journal je voudrais
vous donner de nouvelles d'abord la
première nous vient d'italie où je viens
d'apprendre qu'un nouveau gouvernement
démocrate chrétien avait été formé la
nouvelle a été donnée officiellement par
monsieur giulio andreotti le nouveau
président du conseil
il y à quelques minutes à la télévision
italienne et puis nous allons revenir
sur ce qui se passe en ce moment même en
israël vous le savez je voulais dit tout
à l'heure à 18 heures près cet
après-midi
note aux bus israélien a été attaqué par
un commando de fedayins nous venons par
satellite de recevoir les images les
premières images de cette attaque de
fedayins je vous propose donc de voir
ces les premières images qui nous
parviennent en direct de la télévision
israélienne
voici donc en effet les premières images
qui nous parviennent d'israël d'après ce
que l'on peut savoir à présent l'autobus
qui a explosé près d'une contrée club
transporter une centaine de passagers
rapporte le correspondant de la radio
israélienne
il apparaît à présent que ce sont deux
mais trois autobus et non pas de dons
que les fedayin ont attaqué l'explosion
du bus bloqués près du country club près
de tel aviv a fait plusieurs blessés
très certainement des morts
l'autobus le deuxième capturés samedi
par les fedayin a explosé alors que les
membres du commando s'enfuyait pour se
réfugier non loin de la mer avant que
l'effet rémy ne quitte le bus des
combats très violents les avait opposés
aux forces de l'ordre
les tirs avaient duré plus de dix
minutes depuis les forces israéliennes
continuent à rechercher les membres du
commando ceux ci se seraient réfugiés
non loin au bord de la mer vous l'avez
constaté il s'agissait des premières
images que nous recevions sur ce drame
qui est en train de se nouer
en ce moment en israël pour terminer ce
journal les prévisions de la météo pour
demain elles sont importantes puisque
demain vous devrez vous déplacer pour
aller voter
quand vous rendre dans les bureaux de
vote et bien je vous le dis tout de
suite le temps ne devrait vous poser
aucun problème après la dissipation des
brumes et des brouillards matinaux le
temps sera en effet généralement
ensoleillé le matin et puis au cours de
la journée le ciel devrait se couvrir
tout de même sur le nord ouest de la
france il pourrait même tomber quelques
gouttes d'eau il fera beau il fera chaud
également à peu près partout les vents
eux resteront dans l'ensemble assez
faible voilà donc pour l'actualité de
cette journée notre prochain rendez vous
est fixé aux alentours de 23h45 23h57
hervé claude qui vous tiendra au cou
des derniers développements de
l'actualité et notamment de l'actualité
en israël quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain à 13h à demain bonsoir